we are learning new details about how a
Colorado father killed his pregnant wife
and two young daughters to start a new
life with his mistress the news is just
really sad this morning Christopher
Watts was sentenced yesterday he will
serve three life terms plus 84 years for
tampering with evidence and murdering
his wife Cheyenne
his daughters Bella and Celeste and his
unborn son Nico
mark Strassmann is outside the Colorado
Courthouse where the emotional hearing
took place mark good morning good
morning calculated and cold-blooded
these killings seemed to jar everyone
that they touched even the judge called
it as vicious and inhumane as any case
he has ever handled and it was a dark
side of Christopher Watts that seemed to
come out of nowhere I have no idea who
gave you the right to take their lives
Shanna Watson's grieving parents
struggle with feelings of anguish and
betrayal their own son-in-law murdered
their daughter and two grandchildren
we love you like a son we trusted you
your faithful wife trusted you your
children adored you but then they did
something remarkable
they showed mercy asking the judge to
spare Christopher Watson's life this is
hard to say but may God have mercy on
your soul district attorney Michael
Roark said Shannon died slowly strangled
by her husband he then smothered their
daughters Celeste and Bella who fought
for her life how quickly were you on to
him I want to say it was probably within
the first 24 hours
he was emotionless he was flat it almost
smirking at times when he would talk
about his missing family Roark said
Watts was having an affair with a
co-worker and was unexcited to learn his
wife was pregnant again when you won't
see what happens in his mind his family
had become a hindrance if that's the
case you get a divorce
you don't annihilate your whole family
in August when his family first
disappeared watts publicly pleaded for
their safe return I just want them to
come back at his sentencing he
apologized through his lawyer but
declined to speak himself would you like
to make a statement
and ignored pleas from his own mother to
explain himself we love you
prosecutor my truck told me that he
expects watts to serve his time outside
the state of Colorado for his own safety
what work also told me this kind of
notoriety will follow watts wherever he
goes Noora disturbing to hear all those
details mark thank you